precisamente las sospechas son de que es
el isis y cisca que ya en varios
discursos anteriormente el presidente yo
bailé había dicho que en los talibanes
estaban confrontando sea ese grupo
terrorista que esa era la amenaza
terrorista más grande que enfrentaba la
evacuación estadounidense y la
evacuación de la otan de kabul y cisca y
precisamente lo que se conoce por parte
de oficiales de seguridad lo que se
empieza a hablar en varios medios
nacionales es que el atentado había sido
una persona con un chaleco explosivo que
se acercó a a bill gates y detonó esta
explosión generando hasta el momento 13
muertos y pues decenas de heridos y 13
muertos que un mismo oficial talibán es
el que le confirma a medios ya
reporteros locales pues esta cifra de 13
muertos aunque pues posiblemente esta
cifra aumente el portavoz del pentágono
ha estado muy activo en redes sociales
actualizando la información de lo que
está pasando dijo y confirmó esta
segunda explosión cerca del hotel bauen
también allá de la capital de afganistán
kabul cerca al aeropuerto y llama la
atención que pues se le había advertido
ya varias fuerzas de seguridad de
inteligencia estadounidense que esta
explosión estos ataques terroristas iban
a venir
y pues lo que dicen oficiales de
inteligencia de eeuu es que aunque lo
tengan muy en cuenta era muy difícil
ubicar a una persona con explosivos en
medio de la multitud que se aglomeró a
la sala a la entrada del aeropuerto de
kabul y que entonces era muy difícil
identificar esa persona con un chaleco
explosivo que pues según oficiales es la
versión más que hasta ahora más circula
en los medios de comunicación que haya
sido precisamente eso un chaleco
explosivo una persona que se detonó el
género pues este accidente yo al qirbi
lo decía un portavoz del pentágono
actualizado ha confirmado que se trata
de dos ataques que seguirá informando
sobre lo que esté pasando pero el
departamento de estado
ya le ha dicho a los estadounidenses que
están allá todavía en afganistán que son
aproximadamente 1.500 estadounidenses
que por favor no vayan en este momento
al aeropuerto que es ese que se creen
lejos del aeropuerto de kabul son 1500
estadounidenses que todavía faltan por
evacuar a apenas 5 días de el límite de
la fecha del 31 de agosto que tiene eeuu
para sacar a sus aliados y a sus
ciudadanos estadounidenses cristóbal y
el presidente joe biden ha insistido en
que la fecha máxima de las evacuaciones
debe ser el 31 de agosto sobre las
evacuaciones ha habido algún
pronunciamiento puntual de la casa
blanca
hace tres horas el presidente yo bailé
trino diciendo que ha sacado desde el 14
de agosto aproxima antes de perdón desde
finales de julio ha sacado a 95 mil
personas tanto estadounidenses como
aliados afganos
varios medios también están diciendo que
están en negociación eeuu con el talibán
precisamente para tratar de expandir un
poquito más esa fecha del 31 de agosto
le comparto unas cifras estadounidenses
evacuados de afganistán ha sido son
hasta el momento 4500 faltan 1.500
estadounidenses por evacuar y el york
times' está estimando que pues los
afganos aptos para poder aplicar a estas
visas especiales estadounidenses son más
de 300 mil afganos por el momento la
cifra de afganos evacuados pues no llega
a los 80 mil es decir hay cerca de 250
mil afganos que faltan por evacuar y
pues a partir de estos ataques teniendo
en cuenta la complejidad y las amenazas
terroristas en los en el aeropuerto de
kabul pues ya muchos acá dicen que va a
ser una misión imposible lograr evacuar
estas 250.000 personas ciudadanos
afganos para llevarlos a otros lugares
del mundo y después a eeuu así que pues
directamente por parte de la casa blanca
no ha habido todavía un pronunciamiento
lo que sabemos es que yo bailé está con
el secretario de estado- anthony blinken
y con lloyd austin su secretario de
defensa en el sitio y sin uno más en la
casa blanca muy a la espera de qué va a
pasar y qué está pasando en afganistán
de hecho el presidente o alguien tuvo
que retrasar tuvo que aplazar una
reunión que tenía con el primer ministro
israel